rumor has it and I've done my research
that you partied so hard the night
before your graduation that you missed
it true or false this is true and I
actually well I think we're done how
dare you come here and lecture America
the awkward situation I had to give a
commencement speech and I was thinking
myself how can I kind of bond with the
students and I and I thought what I
would admit honestly that I had missed
my commencement so what happened the
night before your it's I was I was very
sad to be leaving college I had had a
really fantastic time I'd made these
great friends and we stayed up late
reminiscing and probably you know
imbibing more than we should and
honestly I slept clean through it I
actually wait I slept how late did you
sleep till I don't know if I should say
this under I mean I slept till noon at
least I think that I may have slept a
little bit the way that it worked it the
way it worked at Yale that was a big
graduation ceremony in the morning with
the University and the class day speaker
that was the person I was later on and I
miss all that you lately I'm drunk
slept through the class day speaker but
then later on was invited to come back
and be the class take my book and follow
my what I do but but I'd make it to my
degree I did get my yeah yeah we yours
in the afternoon I will not question
mail it anyway what's the big deal by 2
or 3 o'clock I was I wasn't you were ok
bye good [ __ ] you were in good shape by
that
you